as long as we imagine that we are both
exceptional and indispensable in dealing
with Isis we will fail hi I'm Nicolas
way with reason TV and today we are
talking with Gordon Adams he's an
emeritus professor of International
Studies from American University thanks
for talking to us thanks for having in
the latest Republican debate the topic
was US foreign policy and it was foreign
policy but most of the GOP candidates
spent time talk about when they would
deploy the military when did foreign
policy become basically synonymous with
military intervention to some extent
it's been synonymous with it ever since
the beginning of the Cold War at the
beginning of the Cold War George Kennan
who wrote the famous long telegram and
was staff at the Embassy in Moscow
basically said what we ought to be doing
is containing the Soviet Union that was
1947 one Paul mitzi in 1950 authored NSC
68 a famous memorandum sending out
American strategy he basically said yes
we need to contain the Soviet Union and
the way we do it is with military
capability that was the point in time
between that and the Korean War that we
built up a very substantial military and
to some degree ever since then the
instinct in American policy has been to
say the most useful tool to reach for to
demonstrate American leadership to
demonstrate American commitment to
demonstrate the American capacity is our
military capability so since then we've
had a significant military capability
and over time we've enlarged the arena
of action of that capability into a lot
of activities that aren't necessarily
military well yeah talk about that in in
a kind of 21st century context because I
mean we supposedly won the Cold War and
yet we're spending as much in terms of
dollars as we ever were and we've spent
all of the 21st century essentially
involved in too long wars and we're
barely getting started we are spending
about a hundred and fifty billion
dollars more in constant dollars than we
spent in the Cold War average spending
including the Vietnam War in a Korean
War periods so we are spending at an
unbelievably high rate for the military
what are we spending it on
we have the world's largest military the
world's most capable military we not
only spend the most on on military
spending but how much more do we then
you know the next ten countries combined
all of the next ten countries combined
don't reach the American defense budget
the chinese defense budget is estimated
to be somewhere between 120 and a
hundred and eighty billion dollars in
dollar terms not always a good
comparison but significantly less than
the roughly 600 billion dollars that we
spend on our own military so it's much
larger we also have the only military
that is global truly global we can
deploy anywhere fly anywhere sale
anywhere we have the only global
logistics transportation communications
information intelligence basing
infrastructure with over 800 military
installations around the globe there's
no other military in the world that
comes even close so where does it come
and certainly this was on display in the
in the Republican debate and it crops up
in democratic debate Hillary Clinton is
a big supporter of military of the
military and military action but you
know we're constantly being told we have
fewer airplanes you know then George
Washington had we need to be spending
more all of our resources have been
degraded yeah there's a typical mantra
that happens roughly every four years
that is to say every president at
dential election season about the
weakness that the democrats are accused
of imposing on America's military forces
right and so you'll hear that statistics
yes we have a 286 ship Navy it's the
smallest the Navy's been since the
Second World War true and irrelevant
both because the quality of the ships is
substantially better than anything we
deployed in the Second World War and
especially untrue because there's not
another Navy in the world that comes
close in other words you need the Navy
if you think you want a Navy you want
the Navy that you need to have not the
Navy of your wish list the Navy that we
have at 286 ships is the largest and
most capable blue water Navy in the
world more than the Chinese way more
than the Russians and nobody else
matters is this focus on the military's
that a saw is it a sign or a kind of
indication that's so-called soft power
tre cultural exchange you know kind of
hectoring through media and whatnot is
just failed or was it that that's really
never been a serious part of our foreign
policy what what this country really
doesn't have is an integrated foreign
policy where the soft power tools matter
institutionally the Department of
Defense is so much larger than the State
Department or any foreign assistance
agency we have all wrapped into one by a
factor of 12 or 13 21 in budgetary terms
that they simply have an immense
capability that no other institution has
so it's no wonder presidents constantly
reach for the Defense Department when
they want to demonstrate American power
American leadership American
intervention American capability they
reach for the Department of Defense
because it looks like the most organized
deployable can do institution of
American foreign policy and the State
Department doesn't look like that they
don't move as quickly they don't have as
much demonstrable power they don't have
as much flexibility they don't have
additional people they can deploy they
don't have airplanes there's a lot of
things that the aid people in the State
Department diploma test can't do that
the Defense Department will always come
up on the net and say yes sir can do
will do it has the increase of the size
of the military in terms of spending and
reach and the willingness to use it
whether it's in Iraq and Afghanistan and
Libya and Syria and you name it has that
made a safer as a nation it clearly has
not made us safer the biggest weakness
if you will of most of the advocates and
they're there in both parties Democratic
and Republican whether you're a neocon a
conservative interventionist or a
liberal intervention is the big a
disadvantage of using the military is
threefold one we don't do it very well
when we do it Iraq and Afghanistan are
cases in point but if you go back in the
history of the actual use of American
military force we've actually
demonstrably 11 conflict since the end
of the Second World War just one and it
was the 1991 intervention in the Gulf to
throw the Iraqis out of Kuwait it's the
only one you can manifestly say yep went
there did that push them out what
followed is another problem but none
it's the only one when we go in and ask
the military to do civilian jobs helping
with government doing economic
development social services like this
nation nation building we fail we
manifestly fail so in Stella Terry comes
up as the can-do institution and can't
do it and is that because the military
does a poor job at this or it's just it
it's like asking the police to run you
know tote to run the education system
it's like asking the police to run the
education system it's the biggest
problem is to the problems are twofold
one the military doesn't have the
cultural knowledge to know how to do
this in any other country and two they
don't have the core competences to
govern do electric power institute
business investment all those things
that they say that they were going to do
in iraq and afghanistan they're not
competent to do it so we fail the
consequence of that failure for american
national security is manifold in iraq we
can see it by failing to do it we end up
with Isis is there a way to use soft
power to either contain or counteract
Isis or is it something now that we're
faced with a parent military threat
there you got to go in and blow it up
the the conundrum here is that as long
as we imagine that we are both
exceptional and indispensable in dealing
with Isis we will fail because we're
that we are indispensable it's got to be
us thing goes is major American military
intervention I'm not saying that's not
something that we could do but the
blowback consequences of doing that in
the region as we've already seen in Iraq
and Afghanistan are enormous in other
words we do exactly what the Greek
Greeks called tragedy in trying to do
what we think is the right thing we
absolutely inevitably end up with more
enemies more blowback and a worse
reputation so it's a counterproductive
strategy and until we realize that we're
not exceptional and that we can't simply
by saying frog because other countries
and their peoples and their movements to
jump we're going to keep making that
same mistake over and over and over
again but it is no longer useful for our
national security well
we will leave it there thank you so much
Gordon Adams we've been talking to
Gordon Adams he's an emeritus professor
from American University thanks so much
for speaking with us pleasure for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie